The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: All
right, so let's see.
So first we have L1 is
equal to bacon, eggs.
I'm going to short
form-- shorthand this.
L2 is equal to toast and jam.
Brunch-- I should actually
make these arrows-- brunch
is equal to L1.
So this is just
aliasing, which means
brunch is going to point to
whatever L1 object points to.
And if I do L1.append
juice, L1 is now
going to be bacon,
eggs, and juice.
OK?
This L1 has been
mutated to be that.
And since brunch still
points to the same object
that L1 points to, brunch is
now going to point to there.
OK?
So when I do
brunch.extend L2, I'm
going to take whatever brunch
is, which is this part here,
and I'm going to extend it by
L2, which is toast and jam.
OK?
So it's just going to contain
a large list of those five
elements because of this
side effect issue, where
brunch was pointing
to the same thing
that L1 was pointing to, OK?
So it's close, but
I think-- perfect.
Yes, that's the right answer.